well it's the wave of the future and it
has to do with robots the state
department of education is partnering
with first nevada to get every student
globally prepared through a
multi-million dollar investment
what goes into making these types of
things like robotics
whether it be robotic arms meet samuel
engert he's a senior at cimarron high
school and has been learning about
robotics for the past four years because
we have the manufacturing program we are
able to have all the equipment that the
team can use also it's a lot of hands-on
experience stuff that you normally
wouldn't get to do out of high school
thanks to a recent four million dollar
investment from the state engert and
other students can continue their
learning the money will also be used for
outreach part of our goal is to increase
access
to stem
or steam fields especially for our
students who traditionally have not
always had access or english learners
students with disabilities according to
first nevada cimarron high school has
the largest and oldest robotic
competition team in the state with over
50 students they've constructed 120
pound robots and programmed them so it
kind of gives them a whole
pipeline and then expands on those
workforce development skill sets that
the kids need and then of course there's
amazing companies like tesla and switch
and gene haas foundation that are
wanting to hire kids that are in these
programs a promising future for so many
like this student who can't wait for the
next step after high school after high
school i am going to go to college for
mechanical engineering
and the robotics team has inspired me to
go on and continue doing engineering
great stuff there all right these
programs also help students financially
further their education this year there
are 80 million dollars in scholarships
available